welcome to another one of my doctors
adler chalk and talks this time i am
discussing a question that was given to
me by a student through vu
he or she said
what was descartes position on god and
they said that they tried to get some
some answers out of their own professors
but that there was some some
disagreement between them
and so i want to talk about why i think
there might be some disagreement
in part because there's an ambiguity in
the
way the question is put to begin with
when we're talking about views on god
we might mean a lot of different things
descartes definitely has some some views
about god that are that are articulated
in his various works
you know the discourse
meditations
principles
really throughout his work because god
is an important part of his
philosophical system
now that's not the same thing as saying
that descartes believed in god in the
way that some religious believer out on
the street
might mean if we went up to him or her
and we said hey do you believe in god
those aren't quite the same set of
commitments those aren't the same
set of meanings so let's think about a
bunch of different
things that people mean when they talk
about say views on god or
believing in god
descartes has a metaphysical position
all of us do actually whether we
understand ourselves to or not because
we we have some beliefs about the nature
of the universe reality
human beings
other animate things
we have all sorts of
metaphysical commitments that we're
making you know whether we're
materialists or idealists pick whatever
you like
so
we can talk about
views on god in terms of metaphysical
position
being along the lines of
do you believe that there is some sort
of being out there
corresponding to what people tend to
call god
do you
see that as a something that can be
proven if so how do you see that
something that could be disproven and so
how
does god interact with the rest of
the universe
or you know in religious terms with
creation
if so how those would be metaphysical
views as well as being
other types of use
we can talk about religious beliefs and
we can talk about the discipline
that's more concerned with those
theology
um
you know once we get to things
a more positive nature like
did god really give
the
ten commandments to moses
you know on tablets now we're dealing
with with beliefs that are no longer
really metaphysical beliefs they're
about you know
what you might call
empirical events
um
and that's a sort of that's a different
sort of question than asking about you
know a philosopher's
metaphysical beliefs
there are also a lot of things if we
want to distinguish between philosophy
and theology
in a way that's similar to how people
were at the time of descartes
there are there are truths that we could
know
by use of the human mind unaided you
know simply applying natural human
reason
and then there are other truths that we
could know only
by being given them as a revelation and
then perhaps using reason to unpack them
so the notion that god is the christians
have that god as a trinity
that by most philosophers has been seen
as one of those the other type of truth
that has to be known through revelation
so theology would handle that
we can also talk about religious
practice does
you know somebody's
views on god are they revealed in
religious practice if somebody believes
god to be good
how do they interact with god
if they believe that prayer works you
would expect which it could be a
metaphysical belief you would expect
them to actually be praying because you
know if prayer works why the hell
wouldn't you right
if you are committed to
you know theological views like
god is met through the sacraments you
know the teaching of
the catholic church and actually quite a
few of the protestant churches of
descartes time
then that would you know lead to a
certain kind of behavior
we could also talk about descartes
attitude towards religious authority as
well does he
does he take religious authority
as sort of speaking for god or not
so let's look at each of these in turn
very clear that descartes has
metaphysical views on god
now he tells us what those are as a
matter of fact we're going to talk
through the rest of this mostly about
those
he's clearly committed to the view that
god exists
he's clearly committed to the view that
you can prove that god exists that you
can know certain things about god
that god interacts with with other
things in certain ways so
you know we can put a check in his
column on that part
what about
more specifically religious beliefs
well you know descartes is an
interesting and cagey fellow when it
comes to this sort of stuff
you get the impression that
he wanted to keep himself out of
any sort of predicaments or trouble
so he refrained from
saying too much and rocking the boat and
this this goes along with what's often
called the provisional morality
descartes you know according to the
great cartesian project is going to
supply and ethics at one time never
actually does that you know
you know out of
metaphysics
and physics should ultimately ultimately
come
mechanics medicine and morals according
to
this whole great tree thing
he does provide us with something that
you can call provisional ethics though
and in this provisional ethics
he says well you know whatever the
beliefs happen to be of the place where
you are
you should probably go along with them
uh in part you keep yourself out of
trouble that way you're not likely to
lead yourself astray
it's not as if he sees an intrinsic
value or truth in doing that
instead it's more like well if you want
to do philosophy and you don't want
other people to be bothering you with
all these other things that they do get
really worked up about
go along with what the majority of
people are okay with and you know keep
your mouth shut most of the time about
that so i think that when it comes to
descartes religious beliefs and then
other scholars think differently on this
but most of them say
yeah he's not really committed to to
christianity in any sort of
robust sense
and you can see this really clearly when
it comes to religious practice
descartes you know goes to masses when
he needs to
doesn't appear to feel their lack when
he's uh in other places never really
talks much about the sacraments i mean
there's a few bits and pieces here and
there in letters
but it's hard to tell how much of that
is actually just trying to show that his
philosophy is compatible with that of
the
catholic church well not
not the philosophy of the catholic
church because there's no such thing but
the theological views of the catholic
church
he's not committed to to christianity as
a way of life
this is not a central part of who
descartes is
if you compare him to some of his
contemporaries or some of the other
cartesians you know like you say
compared to blaise pascal
or you compare him to
nicholas malbrush
it's very clear by looking at their
lives that descartes is not very
interested in religious practice
so his views on god would apparently be
something like well you know god doesn't
particularly care so much about doing
all these these religious rituals and
things like that
what about religious authority well you
know again descartes is very keen on
getting his philosophy accepted and he's
doing something fairly revolutionary at
the time
and he's also keen on not getting
himself into any sort of unnecessary
trouble
so
you know his views on religious
authority basically end up being
something like hey i'm just doing
philosophy here natural reason
i'm going to leave that higher up stuff
to you religious authorities that are
doubtless better suited to that and have
you know a better access to to the
divine revelation than i do i'm just
going to stick with this
now that sounds like a very humble
way of putting things
but since descartes is sort of
claiming to
to present us with what reason itself
would
would say
how reason itself would see itself what
the right method in using your mind has
to be what all the
right metaphysical views are
he's not actually
putting himself below the theologians
and the church authorities he's actually
in a certain sense placing himself above
that
one way of actually
making religious authorities and their
claims irrelevant is to say
ah you're so far above reason we can't
understand you
we just have to take you on faith
because then as soon as that faith is
gone
they're down here
so
okay so to sum this up
descartes does he is making metaphysical
commitments very clearly having to do
with god when it comes to the other
stuff it seems to be
fairly
along the lines of window dressing
it doesn't appear to be things that were
really core to his philosophical project
the way they were for somebody like
pascal
so let's now look at what were some of
those metaphysical
commitments that he made
well first off he makes arguments about
god's existence and i'm confining myself
here just to the two most
popularly read works of descartes the
meditations and discourse
method
because he does talk about this in other
places as well but he makes arguments
for god's existence in meditations three
and five
and arguably
perhaps even in meditation one
he makes another he makes arguments for
god's existence also in the discourse on
method four
his arguments for god's existence
tend to be
either what we call ontological
arguments based on the idea of god and
unpacking that so that it must include
somehow necessary existence
you see them doing an argument like that
in meditation five also in the discourse
method
or they tend to be an interesting
variety of the cosmological argument
made
it's kind of tricky to get your head
around this made in meditation three
where he's saying something essentially
along the lines of
if
god didn't exist
then where did this idea of god
come from in our minds
given that this idea itself has a
greater type of reality than those of
other ideas and there's a very tricky
proof and i'm not going to try to
do justice to it here but essentially
there's good grounds for seeing it as a
sort of argument from causality but
confined to things that go on in our
mind
maybe also in meditation one like i said
in part because he's saying
if you think about how i came to be
um if i'm not designed by god if i
wasn't created by god
then i have even less likelihood of ever
getting to the truth
if that's an argument for god's
existence a fairly weak argument for
god's existence i think
but it might be one none of us
what else he thinks that god is a
substance
substances are the things that are the
most real in the cartesian system there
are three kinds of substance
bodies or extension physical things that
interact with each other that are
extended in space and time
minds
not extended in space and time connected
up with bodies and kind of tricky to
explain ways
again you know much more to be said
there
and the third one god god is his own
kind of substance totally unique
infinite perfect in every conceivable
way
anything that it's better to be than not
to be
god is that and he's also good descartes
does seem to think of of god in a fairly
non-anthropomorphic way he rejects some
very crude forms of anthropomorphism
he does think that god is similar to us
or at least we are similar to god in
having an intellect and having a will
as a matter of fact he thinks that what
it means for human beings to be in the
image of god
is not our intellect which was a fairly
traditional it's a thomistic you know
and patristic way of looking at it but
in our will he thinks that our will
makes us more like god and descartes
view of god is what we call a
volunteeristic view of god if god wanted
to change the rules
for how things work he could you know do
that anytime he wants to
why are the laws of mathematics or the
laws of logic you know or even those of
physics set up the way they are
god chose that
that's the end of the explanation there
god provides
in the cartesian system god provides the
possibility
of attaining something that's really
important for descartes and that's
certainty
if you think about the whole
project of the meditations
begins with hyperbolic data
begins by rejecting previous opinions
stripping them away
first starting with the senses then
starting with even like to know the
truths of mathematics
and finally getting to the point where
descartes can say well there's one thing
i know that's i exist
and then i can start working out from
that what is this i exist what is it for
me to exist on a thinking thing here's
these different modes of thinking
but
without god
he gets
stuck in what we would call solipsism
which is where you said the self and the
self can only have knowledge of the self
and it's you know what is appearing to
it and it can't be sure that there's
anything truly outside
anything other than the song
god gets descartes out of that
predicament
he allows him first of all to think you
know well there is a god there's
something greater than me so that puts
things in perspective
and then he also invited by the the
midpoint of the meditations is allowing
descartes to say that he can trust
that things are the way that he
perceives them clearly and distinctly
things that he perceives through his
mind things not through the senses but
but through reason through the intellect
so you know you can trust that a
triangle actually does have angles that
add up to you know
180 degrees it's not going to change
tomorrow
and then you can even get to the point
where you have an external world that
you can
more or less reliably believe in you can
you can be an error about some things
but you don't have to be worried about
the idea that it's almost a dream
the last thing i'm going to say about
this has to do with this use of god
blate's pascal i'm going to let him have
the last word
blaze pascal was a much more committed
religious thinker after living a kind of
liberty in existence
these things would would apply to blaise
pascal the ones that don't apply to
descartes do applies to pascal
and he says descartes uses god
he brings him into his system just to
set the world in motion and then he has
no more use for it
and i think that's actually a good
interpretation
of descartes view so if your view and
asking about descartes when you know you
read all this this god talk is well was
he a religious guy
he wasn't really a religious guy it's
possible to have all sorts of views on
god or the divine without having very
strong or even any religious commitments
and i think that
i'm not going to say descartes didn't
have any religious commitments but they
certainly were not an important part of
his life